[Music]
there it is and
welcome back to off the record where we
get to talk about whatever we
want we got dante back in this seat oh
we got a new host up in here
hey it's my job we got a new host up in
here
anthony's the news cherry popping his
cherry as a host it's not about me
though guys it's about dante he's back
in the seat okay
what it is about you i'm deflecting all
day because we're talking about
hosts hosting like you and then we're
just we're just talking about
like our show and you're like yo yo i
don't want to be too forward or nothing
but
i'm kind of down a host and i'm like
what
you get you fly for the job don't be
throwing those stories out it's been a
tough year
that's what i respect about you is
you're always like a dog he stays humble
is that you're always hustling and
you're always like like you're
you're one of the few dancers that i
know that are like let me just see what
else i can do you know
because most dancers are lazy damn
that's messed up that's true
i like how he's like he's like you're
one of the dancers i know who's like
what else can i do
sweet moves bro he's pretty good yeah
you look like
leo and uh great what was it uh no i was
about to say great gatsby it's not
it's the he's uh he's though
that move i [ __ ] love that meme dude
dante's been here so many times though
now it doesn't even feel like
he's a guest the liam that whipple wall
street movie is like that classic
you know i don't want to be like the
classic white boy break dance
pop and move with that but he did do it
but he needed to do it for the jiff
generation
because like that wasn't like really
available before right but now like
that's the one and not any white boy
anyone that can't
really pop black water other big just do
that one move rhythmless
that's the one and he did that one move
all right everybody admit it here did
everybody at least be doing the wave
in like junior high school dances or
something i know for sure i'm for sure
for sure yes at a baseball game when you
stand up real quick it's not the
last that's the big way i don't like
that one yeah yeah just like the way
we're just doing the way
come on he he for sure has done it is it
called the wave the wave
dude i can't do it though that's the
thing i can't even [ __ ] do but you've
done it that's hard bro the crazy thing
so i remember we
were trying to figure out as kids right
you didn't know how to do it yeah and
then i met a guy who actually taught me
where these are the steps right wow oh
you're ticking are you taking it now
how do these bounces like end up into it
and then you end up like doing it and i
was like
what the [ __ ] that's crazy oh my gosh
like jim carrey he can't control his own
body and [ __ ]
i knew joe was super sub that was really
impressive nice
doesn't do that [ __ ] in junior high
while talking that was impressive
spinning around on their head and [ __ ]
bart's a dancer too i see you did you be
boy
i tried to but all the filipinos are way
better what was your move like you
everyone had to move
you're like
i could do this before but you know when
you do a windmill until freeze and you
freeze on your shoulder
yeah that was me the power you had some
power he had that power
that's the only thing i had my first
move was the coffee grinder oh yeah
that's a good first move
please i don't know if i could do it
anymore dude your center of gravity is
so different from when you're a kid
hold on let me see okay when you're a
kid you could just swing anything around
it's been over 20 years okay yeah i
think are you careful
you need to warm up oh that's the coffee
cup
and the hat still stays on oh there it
is oh [ __ ] there it goes oh damn he goes
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
oh yeah that's the problem right now
yeah it's really hot now really hot i
don't remember feeling so tense
from the coffee crowd that was a basic
move maybe your pants were more loose
back in the night maybe because
yeah that's true we wore parachutes as
pants yeah my neck hurts someone called
osha
my parachute pants do they sell those
anymore
yeah for sure probably in japan
somewhere in the depth probably actually
probably resurging i think i got a pair
for christmas
don't they call them joggers now i don't
know they're made from parachute
material right oh you tell them like the
crotch is all the way down here like
that drop crotch like nc hammers that
was a
that's the drop crop no it's like hella
um it's like made from parachute
material yeah it's
literally made of like what seems like
polyester nylon parachute style material
that's like loose flowy and super baggy
right maybe cinch up at the ankle but
like
overflowing over like a latin pants like
a muffin top like fat person's got a
small polo on what's the most
embarrassing pants you've owned because
i bought a pair of pants from a place
called wasteland which is like bougie
um goodwill and i found a pair of pants
i must have been like 21 years old i had
just moved to la
and i was like i gotta dress more l.a
you guys want to how you did you thought
about that yeah yeah well cause guys
always wear those wet shirts
especially back then this is like a wet
shirt dude it looks like they're [ __ ]
wet it looks like there's
like those raver shirts yeah yeah yeah
well it looks like a hologram
yes and it's all shiny but the shirts
themselves look wet for some reason
yeah it's like you're from europe
liquidy so i was like i'll get a [ __ ]
wet shirt so that way when i go to like
um like my friends wanted to go to clubs
and stuff she was like i'll get a wet
shirt and i saw these pants and i was
like
they have [ __ ] beads on them i was
like that's weird i was like but that's
some la [ __ ] so they had like
beads going on the lids and stuff and
like they're kind of faded and [ __ ]
you had raver packs i had i had raver
pants that i bought at wasteland didn't
everybody have river pants
no i've never had no jenko you get some
jinkos i just i don't even know what to
do
with raver pads dude i go home i bring
him to my
chick at the time and she's like you
can't wear any of this
like you can wear it to a gay club but
you cannot wear this
like with me you cannot do that even
then they'll be like you're doing too
much
well you know jingle pants are like
super baggy river pants which i've never
had like it
almost goes over your shoe yeah for sure
but
so many years we had we're all baggy and
then when
when the when the tighter jeans kind of
came in it was the funniest thing to go
shopping on my homies that we're all
hip-hop dudes
but we're going to the store to buy your
first pair of skinny jeans after like 20
years so
hard dude when me and joe were doing
like james that [ __ ] and you're like
this
feels [ __ ] weird yeah we were i think
we're like 10 years behind what everyone
else was wearing because we just
couldn't get ourselves to do it even
though everyone was
and we're still behind because now
everyone's going back to baggy now it's
back and you're back to bed and now i
just finally got comfortable with
like tighter jeans i'm gonna stick to
those but straight leg that was the key
because then you're not wearing skinny
jeans
you're like are these straight leg okay
cool but they were skinny jeans but they
weren't called skinny jeans yeah
and then you went into slim you know i'm
talking about slim fit that helped me
hold my head up high while i wore them
but i was like
i was like i know but the first time you
fit them in some
material squeezing your ass and thigh it
feels nice
sexy huh you feel very weird coming out
that dress room like dude but you kind
of feel hot yeah you kind of feel
hot but you kind of feel no i like baggy
jeans it just
feels more comfortable i went back to
bought some bag i was like
at the mall and bought some bagging yeah
yeah it's coming back it feels kind of
like floating
it's fun you know it was a hard one when
you talk about embarrassing uh pants
uh i spent probably like when i was in
like early college i probably spent like
200 bucks on some jeans
at a v suit or some [ __ ] like that it
was like distressed it was like tight
right
and i was like oh okay i [ __ ] stick
my foot through and my foot goes
into the distress and i ripped the legs
happened to me before
you added more style to it yeah but the
only problem is
you if you rip it a little bit you can
add style but if you rip it where it's
uh it's
everything's just stretched and flayed
but then yeah it's a flap and it's a
very clean cut
cut right and it's like damn it first
yeah first
yeah first used you got to get a safety
pin in this i hated it
200 bucks yeah you know when like 200 is
like your entire
everything yeah i'll still be mad if i
lose 200 right yeah that's still
yeah i lost 200 crypto every day baby
every single day it's upsetting i just
lost it right now right now coming back
then like the
reverse jet bezos no i stuck my foot
through
uh i remember yeah getting a distressed
jeans as well doing the exact same thing
trying to take them back did you try to
do that no
it's like you shot yeah i didn't
try these on i should have tried them on
and there's like a [ __ ] hole in it
like with my foot size
no they didn't go for it it's not your
shoe stuck in this [ __ ] [ __ ]
emergency jeans
past distress but i mean they're just so
cool right like you know you want
you just want to fit in yeah you're kind
of cool kids they're pretty cool
some girls some girls went too far where
like are you even wearing jeans anymore
yeah that like that's a very funny phase
you're just like damn this girl
trying to pretend like she got jeans on
but they're not it's like they're cut
right at the g string
connect again until the ankle right and
you're like are those like i'm into it
but i'm just saying like
they really changed i remember 21 first
starting to go clubbing
and then you see like you know you see
like what people wear in the movies
right
and you're like what are you really
supposed to just wear a blazer just
for the [ __ ] of it with jeans and like
yeah shiny shoes and shirts no shirt on
just a blazer and you try it on you go
you go you go and you go shopping you
put it on you're like
i don't know man it's just kind of weird
and it just it was just
but then you go to the club and that's
what everyone's wearing so it doesn't
look weird
but you're still like i don't know if i
can do this is weird and i don't think
i've ever crossed
that line because i feel like i would
have so much fun styling you for like a
week
you killed it i just need a t-shirt man
they just need to let t-shirts and
shorts into clubs and i think i'll be
good
you have you know there's like in those
like really ratchet just like kanye
though
that kind of t-shirt yeah that's true
like a thousand dollar t-shirt
with a bunch of holes yeah distressed
t-shirt balenciaga t-shirt
yeah yeah it's gotta say supreme and
they're like you could come in it's
gonna say supreme like a thousand times
today's video is brought to you by
upstart upstart
is an easy way to pay off all your
credit card debt
all online baby yeah i'm about to use it
for some car parts that i need so
there's
a big sale that's going on for my truck
that i just got
and what sucks is the sale is about to
end and my next
paycheck doesn't come in in time so i
know
that if i waited i could pay it off but
then i'll save almost
five grand if i buy it now so what's
cool about upstart is i can go on the
website
put in my info there's a bunch of loan
application info in addition to just
your typical credit score like your
education and your job your job all that
other stuff
and i could put that in and it's just a
five minute online rate check
and within the next business day you can
get up to 50 000
luckily i only need 10 g's but i can
save that much so it's worth it for me
so if you want to pay off your debt
all with a personal online loan and do
this
all online and find out if you get
qualified for the loan
super duper fast upstart is for you
just go to upstart.com off the record to
see if they can help
lower your monthly payment and there's
all kinds of things that go into what
qualifies you for your loan
from your credit score to education
history to employment history all kinds
of other things on the application go to
upstart.com
off the record like when do you know
when when is that clicking moment
where i feel like there's like adult
clothes that you're like okay it's time
for me to wear adult clothes when i put
on these adult clothes
it feels right suits especially as a kid
watching james bond you put on your
first [ __ ] suit and you're like oh
[ __ ] out of like james bond that's right
you put that clip on tyler yeah you're
like
i'm a man [ __ ] but the half
suits are the weird part
like the best yeah i don't like vests
though i don't believe in that
i do some best sometimes i'll see some
vet it gets too close to the steampunk
people
for me yeah it's a personal choice yeah
exactly what's the [ __ ] stopwatch
first of all it's dapper second of all
i'll [ __ ] with the stopwatch you [ __ ]
with steampunk people
all sucks you're like we have to be in
downtown for this i'll [ __ ] put on a
monocle
just for the [ __ ] of it i'll look like
hawk but you could pull it off hawks be
rocking that monocle yeah i can't do it
[ __ ] has a monocle
oh yeah he does does he have a monocle
in a pocket watch he has it all
yeah who's hot and he's wearing a vest
you know oh dj
oh yeah i'm sorry yeah yeah
who sits right there h-o-k h-o-k damn
see stuff like that cause i think i'm
too practical right if i'm buying like a
monocle and a stopwatch the next thing i
think of is
where what's my form of storage at home
i don't have a drawer full of other
stock watches
i'll rock with a stop watch where do you
put it where do you put a stopwatch in
your [ __ ] no at home how do you store
it velvet cases you can get with glass
tops on amazon for i don't got all those
things put on the hook bart you got
hooks in your garage right next to when
you sleep at bedford right next to like
your truck
put it by your keys bro oh yeah the
treasure chest yeah get a [ __ ]
treasure chest
how do you hold a monocle in your eye
bro that's too much monocle is too much
you got to be a certain kind of person
but hawk looks good in it you never had
a monocle
that's that's enough well they may i
always thought the monopoly had a
monocle he did
no he doesn't he doesn't who doesn't he
has one big ass
mandela effect because of the ace
ventura too though oh yeah because that
guy had a [ __ ] monologue
i'm pretty sure i think the flanders
peanut but that that's a mandela effect
thing the plants are
peanut the the pocket watch was for men
and wrist watches were for women
isn't that crazy
[Laughter]
i feel like i saw something that cartier
is the one who created
the wristwatch well the wristwatch
became party though
i knew you were going to go for that
i knew you would i'm proud of you i'm
proud of you oh thank you
already she just released that she got a
you know she's pregnant again some
instagram posts is she still with the
same dude i don't know
she's sorry she looks good pregnant hey
who's really good who says that she
looks good
pregnant yeah yeah that's worse as
opposed to i don't know
who's the rapper that got shot in the
foot it was a female rapper that got
shot in the floor by another rapper uh
by the short dude by um
that was this whole story today yeah no
no no back then was it it was like
during pandemic
[ __ ] was megan beast died yeah yeah it
was about she got shot in the foot
who's the top who's the short dude uh
short dude with tory lanez that's who it
is was she pregnant i wish
no i don't think so but back to bart's
comment about cardiff he looks good
pregnant she does she looks really good
pregnant huh and bart what do you think
what stage
what do you think about pregnant women
normally bro i'm not gonna say anything
what's up anthony
did you mean to look good as in like
[ __ ] or you mean like oh she's still
like not a fat she's glowing or whatever
you guys want to fill in the blanket
i definitely think you know pregnant
look can get really sexy
especially if you really uh again i'm
visualizing my own woman just being
pregnant it's awesome already yo there
is
there is pregnant porn dude oh [ __ ] yeah
i would never
click on that dude he's the idiot of
jones
bro the legend of the last pole this is
the temple he's like
he's like the temple of porn i don't
know if i should
should i make the swap don't go down
that corridor no go down and grab it and
a big-ass
rock comes out and i'm like oh no it's
the cops that's the car
pregnant woman that's not your wife like
says just some single pregnant woman oh
[ __ ]
like a years out in the dating scene and
you were just like well
you was out in the dating scene and and
the one you went for was the prank
you just you just not you went for it
just happened i read some red flags
i'm not saying i did i'm just saying
would you do you like downloaded the
wrong dating app you thought it was for
christians but it's actually for
pregnant vision
and then you fall in love and then
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah would you have
a problem with your problem with it is
the egg like about to pop or her any
turn into an audi
it's like it's like it's a seven month
situation [ __ ]
i don't know she has some needs joe she
has some needs yeah yeah
baby daddy's still around cardi b looks
good in seven months how did i meet her
i met her at the club
you met her you met her at the froyo
shop you met her after that
she had a massive craving and you met
her at the program on the blockchain
i do wish biology was different because
if it was different
and let's say he's going to justify
pregnant women right now like let's say
like
let's say if you busted nuts into a
pregnant lady right yeah
and then that sperm can get accelerated
to what
the current situation is i think would
make guys way hornier
what does that mean he's saying
something i don't understand that
i get it i get it tactical example i
guess
right if she was six months pregnant but
i knew
the more i busted in her i could have
like 12 taikas coming out i'll be
busting in
all day and i'll have like 12 kids oh i
don't get it
[Laughter]
it's like stuffing your clothes into the
luggage dude
i thought it was like say joe has a wife
yeah and you just
and you and her [ __ ] and you bust in his
pregnant wife and you turn it more into
bart
yeah so it's like the pregnancy the
pregnant chick is getting more and more
bartified as you as you don't know
that's not what i heard
but it said he's like oh that's just
crazy you duplicate the baby 80 times
i'm like what exactly
i don't uh let's say see we all feed
differently
i was with steve on that one is it a
clone or is it like a dog where they
have a litter of like
five no yeah like a dog slightly
different okay
your sperm is breaking up the egg in a
different way what i'm doing is you're
trying to
you're trying to like get a litter to
come out
one has a spot on his eye like that yeah
wait does that mean all dogs are like
[ __ ] quadruplets and [ __ ] i don't
think that's how that works is that how
that works
i don't think like that the dog daddy's
going in there and he's like you know i
want like 12 more
no but it's one nut right yeah it's one
nut one
but they have like three or four like
six eggs in there one time as opposed to
like humans got like
one egg and so i think it's every time
they bust you i think that's wrong
excited bro like look it up what are we
doing what are we doing jk science
dude that'll be hilarious and we make a
science chat because
we obviously know exactly how dogs bust
and we know about pregnancy and [ __ ]
like that right
ovulation we know all this stuff yeah in
a way i think we already have a science
channel but that's just me
but back to the pregnancy what did you
think yeah i thought he was just saying
that like let's say
your hypothetical wife again was like
seven months pregnant right
with your baby right and if he goes in
and he just busts the nut inside
then he doesn't have to wait nine months
he's already accelerated into a seven
month period of his kid
wow like cutting the line yeah i'm not
alone that's the perfect analogy it's
cutting them off i'm not a line cutter
i'm more of a luggage stuffer
i was watching this thing and there's um
this one native culture that
was because you know not all american
indians had the same culture right they
had some that were monogamous and some
tribes were like what do you call it
poly [ __ ] polyamorous
oh yeah yeah and one was like whoever
slept with that girl if she got pregnant
they were all the dads yeah that's i
read that too you read that too
it's like the tribe was like not even
the tribe is the [ __ ] like the kid you
know
they didn't think about marriage like
yeah they didn't think they all slept
with each other just kind of like roll
someone whoever got pranked they don't
know who the father was it was just like
a child of the tribe yeah there's no dna
test
everyone plays the daddy everyone plays
with daddy yeah that's kind of cool
which is pretty cool i don't know about
that i don't know about that
but for back then hey that's pretty cool
now that's that's like some
some patchy stuff but if you're living
in a tribe situation
if you're living in a tribe situation
that's a simple sipper
think about it though right like if if
you
like for the guys that just want to bust
nuts all day and then
and then and then who's going to have
like visitation rights right
some people are better at being fathers
huh some people are like that's their
skill
right in the trunk and some guys are
like good at just father and [ __ ]
that's that's why we evolved there's
some guys good at [ __ ] there's some
guys that be
getting up at father yeah but do you
think the guys who
who aren't good at [ __ ] think they're
good at [ __ ] because i secretly hope
i'm not one of those
yeah i think about that too like do i
think i'm really good you should never
shoot yourself to like just keep it in
your fantasy or mine
you know what i'm saying because you're
just gonna disappoint yourself
you